ننوه الى مجموعه من الاخبار العاجله التي
ظهرت على شاشتنا قبل قليل القياده الوسطى
الامريكيه تقول اسقطنا اث اث عش عشره
مسيره وثلاثه صواريخ مضاده للسفن وصاروخي
كروز اطلق الحوثيون جنوب البحر الاحمر
تقول ايضا القياده الوسطى الامريكيه انها
لم ت انه لم تقع اي اضرار للسفن جنوب
البحر الاحمر جراء هجوم الحوثيين ولم يبلغ
عن
اصابات وكان المتحدث العسكري لانصار الله
الحوثيين قد قال انهم استهدفوا سفينه
بصواريخ بعد رفضها للمره الثالثه رسائل
تحذيريه كما استهدفوا بمسيرات مواقع
عسكريه في ام الرشراش ومناطق اخرى بفلسطين
المحتله نفذت القوات البحريه في القوات
المسلحه اليمنيه بعون الله تعالى عمليه
استهداف لسفين
تجاريه ام اس سي يونايتد وذلك بصواريخ
بحريه مناسبه وقد جاءت عمليه استهداف
السفينه بعد رفض طاقمها وللمره الثالثه
نداءات القوات البحريه وكذلك الرسائل
التحذيريه الناريه المتكرره كما نفذ سلاح
الجو المسير بالقوات المسلحه اليمنيه
عمليه عسكريه بعدد من الطائرات مسيره على
اهداف عسكريه في منطقه ام الرشراش ومناطق
اخرى في فلسطين المحتله ان القوات المسلحه
اليمنيه تؤكد استمرارها في دعم واسناد
الشعب الفلسطيني ضمن واجبها الديني
والاخلاقي
والانساني ان القوات المسلحه اليمنيه تؤكد
استمرار عملياتها في البحرين الاحمر
والعربي ضد السفن الاسرائيليه او المتجهه
الى موانئ فلسطين المحتله حتى ادخال ما
يحتاجه قطاع غزه من غذاء ودواء ان القوات
المسلحه اليمنيه تؤكد على ما جاء في
بياناتها السابقه بشان منع مرور كافه
السفن الاسرائيليه او المتجهه الى موانئ
فلسطين المحتله مع حرصها الكامل على
استمرار حركه الملاحه البحريه الى كل
الوجهات باستثناء الكيان الاسرائيلي e